yo there was a year and everybody
remember this that I I've borrowed $100
from 14
people I mean everybody knew it cuz it
was a thing it was like lesli needs
money you know what I'm saying Eric
Griffin Eric Griffin gave me $200 like
uh Steve uh Steve renzis gave me like I
think $300 I think it was like
$300 um I Edwards gave me $900 what a
nice man yo like I mean these are people
that I remember Bobby Lee and this is
real talk Bobby Lee paid my rent three
months in a row a real talk and
then it it then too like cuz he taught
me too about money because he was like
he was on that like when I came when I
came again it I don't know if I really
needed it and I think he knew that and
he was like no I'm not going to give it
to cuz I know you don't he was like but
if you really like you're like he was
always there yeah
so it's it's like I already know who the
real people are